hi this is dr gregory sadler
i'm a professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason i o
where we put philosophy into practice
i've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years
and i find that many people run into
difficulties reading classic
philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
i come in
to help students and lifelong learners
i've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube
many viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos
each of them focused on one core concept
from an important philosophical text
i hope you find it useful as well
chapter 8 of peter singer's book the
most good you can do is an interesting
set
of on the one hand arguments and
summaries
and speculations and on the other hand
some
very important insights about the
possibilities for reason
and emotion all kind of mixed up
together it begins by talking about
how bernard williams is claiming
something about human beings and their
capacity to take the point of the unit
point of view of the universe and then
saying effective altruists seem to have
achieved what williams thought
cannot be done as you know sort of like
a
a challenge and the question here then
really
in this this chapter is how has
effective altruism's characteristic
approach
come about how is it possible if
big heavy hitters like bernard williams
are saying
it can't be done you know and he brings
up some
some culture critics as well like david
brooks and
other people how is it that that there's
this massive movement out there
and we should remind ourselves well what
are some of the key characteristics of
effective altruism
that are being put on the table here one
of these
is taking the point of view of the
universe that's what the chapter
begins with and what does it mean to
take the point of view of the universe
it means to
move back from one's own individual
perspective
one's attachment to oneself and one's
own interest
egoistic perspective right and one's own
connections with other people in the
small circles
around us and to think about things in a
larger context and you know singer
points out
the fact that this detachment is not
total but it does make an
important difference to how effective
altruists live
so it doesn't have to be complete or an
effective altruist is
you know a hypocrite or something like
that singer says we have to be realistic
about this nobody is going to be
perfectly you know universe minded
thinking but we can be more or less
there's a continuum there
and then the next key trait comes up in
that very passage he says
it's based on reasoning of a kind that
comes
close to evaluating how they're living
from a point of view that is independent
of their own dispositions projects
and affections right so there's two
things he's signaling there this
point of view of the universe or at
least not just us
and then a capacity to use reason
to live ethically doesn't mean that you
can't use other things
but reasoning would be central to this
approach and that's what turns some
people off
on it there's another really key trait
to effect of altruism that he's talking
about in this chapter
which is what part of what makes it
effective altruism
valuing the numbers of people affected
as
central and this this is where we can
say listen effective altruism might not
be
exactly the same thing as utilitarianism
but it's pretty darn close
you know there's a lot of overlap
there's not a lot of as people say
daylight between these two things and
really central to the utilitarian
perspective and ethics and program you
could say
is saying that everybody's outcomes
whether it be pleasure and pain or you
know some other
measure matter as much as everybody
else's and we need to take into account
the numbers
that are being affected so some things
will become you know
a good solution if more people are
positively affected by them even though
they it was a bad solution
before in the past from a utilitarian
point of view
so you know is it possible for a person
to adopt
those perspectives well yeah i mean
utilitarians have been around
since utilitarianism started right and
even before that
people can be identified as utilitarian
before the word came into parlance so
obviously it is a human possibility
what singer is more concerned to think
about is
well how on the one hand how did this
come about
and how has it become a viable movement
in the present
when it didn't seem to have that much
traction in the past
and you know what's the relationship
between reasoning and other forms of
motivation
including the emotions in this so
singer is you know very committed to
um what he calls sociobiology you know
providing evolutionary
points of view on these sorts of things
to buttress
his his views and he talks about
evolutionary and
social development so he says that
if we consider uh here we go
the possibility our capacity to reason
can play a critical role
in a decision to live ethically offers a
solution
to the perplexing problem that effective
altruism would otherwise pose for
evolutionary theory
and he says there's no difficulty
explaining why evolution would select
for capacity to reason right
smarter we are in certain respects the
more we're likely to survive
pass on our genes not get eaten by the
the big cats on the savannah whatever
you know solve problems figure out how
to make fire and transport
all those sorts of things those involve
reasoning or the intellect or whatever
you want to call it our higher
cognitive capacities is part of what set
us apart and then you know making tools
having language
all of that sort of stuff big advantage
right so
he goes on and he says if our capacity
to reason
also enables us to see that the good of
others
is from a more universal perspective as
important as our own good
then we have an explanation for why
effective altruists act in accordance
with such principles
you know like our ability to do higher
mathematics this use of reason to
recognize fundamental moral truths
would be a byproduct of another trait or
ability
that was selected for because it
enhanced our reproductive fitness so
what he's saying here is not that
through evolution
we would have developed this moral
capacity
because it was advantageous for us
directly instead of you saying listen we
develop these other cognitive capacities
this is something that kind of rides
along and turns out to be a possibility
and it it also conduces to individual
and group survival
and so therefore you know that's why we
we have this this ability
not necessarily a you know realized
ability in every case but an ability to
step back and think about things in a
larger perspective that doesn't just
include us doesn't just include our
groups but
it could include humanity as as such um
this is highly speculative and it's
perfectly fine that it's highly
speculative
he's in essence you know telling an
interesting story here
a little bit later on you know he's
going to talk about
iq scores going up and
about you know effective altruism
emerging now here we go
we can ask why effective altruism
emerges the movement only now
have people's reasoning abilities
suddenly improved
and he says yeah as a matter of fact
that's that's the case so
here's the socio part of the
sociobiology
affluent nations a sizable segment of
the population lives very comfortably
does not have to worry about economic
security
so the need to find meaning and
fulfillment in life comes to the fore
many people turn to effective altruism
substantial wealth is now coming to a
new generation of people
who work in areas that analyze data and
evidence we're going to talk about that
more technological changes that make it
possible for effective altruists to
connect with each other via the internet
have been important
and he says these developments might
well be sufficient triggers
for the emergence of effective altruism
even if our reasoning abilities had
remained static
but it looks like our reasoning
abilities across the population
have actually been going up in time
which is kind of funny because you know
each older generation is like these kids
these days they don't actually know
anything they can't reason anything if
that's if what singer's saying is
correct
then that would be completely false on
the part of those old fuddy duddies who
are complaining right and telling the
kids to get off their lawn and
all that sort of stuff um so
that you know again interesting
speculations could be true
we don't really know um what about
this interest in numbers that's kind of
a uh feature that we should we should
consider
and again uh rather speculative given
how singer is putting it out there but
this this capacity to look
at the numbers of people involved as
being relevant being important being
something
that we need to bring to the fore really
essential to effective altruism
and utilitarianism so singer
says that people who are already
you might say primed to engage in
abstract reasoning or value
abstract reasoning we might even say who
see the
relevance and results of abstract
reasoning
are more inclined to think in terms of
numbers there is also a very interesting
uh remark that i think we we should
consider as well he says that
i'm not trying to paint effective
altruists as coldly ration
rational calculating machines holden
karnovsky
has blogged about what he sees as the
misconception that effective altruists
are in order
to act as rationally as possible
suppressing their passion suppressing
the affective
side of themselves and karnovsky says
effective altruism is what we are
passionate about
we're excited by the idea of making the
most of our resources
and helping others as much as possible
and that's that's you know
what a lot of people say you know i'm
interested in the numbers the numbers
talk to me the numbers give me a thing
to be excited and passionate about i
i'm happier that i can help two thousand
people
rather than just one thousand people or
twenty people
uh and that's that's a motivation for uh
people is is that
fostered by being in tech fields
maybe maybe not you know probably not
is it fostered by having had a
mathematics degree
somewhere in the background maybe who
knows right this is all very speculative
then he also brings up joshua green's
model of a point and shoot camera
as being like what we do with morality
which i think
you know there's something to this but
again he's telling he's engaging in some
storytelling here
green suggests as he says that the way
most people make moral judgments can be
thought of akin to taking photographs
with a camera that's normally used in
point-and-shoot mode but can be switched
to a manual mode that overrides the
automatic settings
when we're confronted with a situation
calling for moral judgment we usually
have an instinctive gut reaction
that tells us when something is wrong
notice he says tells us when something
is wrong
not tells us when something is right nor
tells us how to balance things out
nor you know tells us what's ethically
salient in the situation just
tells us what is wrong so we're already
dealing with a very reductive
treatment of morality here like a
point-and-shoot camera our intuitive
responses are quick and easy to operate
and in normal circumstances yield good
results
that's debatable but in rare situations
with special features they can lead us
astray in that case we will do better if
we switch to manual mode
that is put aside our instinctive
reactions and think the issue
true so the idea behind this is we only
really do ethics
in the sense of like thinking about
stuff and moral reasoning
practical reasoning when we're
confronted with
weird situations one-offs you know
things that are outside of our
our normal sphere how normal is this
picture
i leave that up to you to think about it
doesn't certainly doesn't map on to
my experience even before i began
studying philosophy and ethics but you
know
psychologists love these sorts of uh
you know models and he does say
something kind of interesting here which
again i don't think we want to draw too
much from he talks about doing brain
studies and asking people to make
judgments about trolley problems
while images were taken of their brain
activity and the
the assertion here is that you know when
they're they're engaging in utilitarian
thinking about this or effective
altruist thinking about this
the more cognitive sides of their their
brain are lighting up
and in other cases they're not now you
know can we draw huge conclusions from
this
probably not so a lot of these are
interesting speculations
really in the realm of moral philosophy
rather than anything scientific
but you know they could be decent enough
for clarifying things and motivating
things
the really key question that comes up in
this chapter that i think is is
absolutely important
does reasoning have to conflict with or
repress
emotions particularly if it's reasoning
in this very big substantive sense about
thinking about the good
for other people what we could call
practical reasoning prudential reasoning
not just instrumental i've already got
my
ends set how do i achieve those ends but
rather
thinking in a much much broader sense
so emotional attachments
or responses or dispositions however we
want to consider this entire affective
side of ourselves
singer says listen these are not
incompatible
with effective altruism he brings up the
example of
you don't have to stop feeling affection
for and loving your child
in order to you know make some
sacrifices and send money overseas where
it's going to benefit thousands of
children
rather than just you know your own child
as a matter of fact you could even work
that cut that kid into it you can be
like
all right now we're gonna think about
our charitable giving and we're gonna do
it in a very
prudential way you can model that
behavior with your child who you love
right the other thing is you know he
talks about reasoning
working in conjunction with emotion
now can reasoning work in conjunction
with all emotion not necessarily
you know singer brings up the example of
you know
egoism right so that could actually get
in the way
my own selfish desires of of proper
practical reasoning
along these lines racism
nationalism he also brings up as
possibilities that could get in the way
um but empathy could could actually if
it's you know
not just listened to as the voice of god
or the
you know still silent voice within that
decides everything for you
the ultimate you know arbiter but it's
brought in
sort of like an advisory uh voice
could be quite helpful and could
reinforce what reason needs to do
this by the way this point of view is
not something radically new we see this
in aristotelian and platonic and stoic
and a lot of christian thought in in the
ancient period and even going into the
middle ages
we see this represented in quite a few
modern thinkers
so this is not something absolutely
radically
new this idea of integrating emotion at
least in some respect
and proper practical reasoning where
neither one of them are taken as
like absolutely pure or the
uh you know infallible voice but they
have to you know work with each other
and kind of
balance each other with reasoning taking
the main role
you